(Rauschen)
(Unruhige Musik,
hektische Alltagsgeräusche)
(Stille, erleichtertes Ausatmen)
Die Welt ist hektisch.
Meditation scheint
das ultimative Gegenmittel zu sein.
Alle wollen möglichst
zen und mindful sein.
Katy Perry, Oprah und etliche CEOs
schwören darauf.
Millionen von Menschen nutzen Apps
wie "Headspace" und "Calm".
Riesige Horden
suchen auf Meditationsretreats
in Indien und Tibet
Antworten auf spirituelle Fragen.
Sie wollen tiefe, tranceähnliche
Bewusstseinszustände erreichen.
Für einige ist Mediation
vielleicht ein Klischee,
esoterischer Nonsens.
Andere sind davon überzeugt, dass
die Jahrtausende alte Praktik uns:
... machen kann.
Heute geht es darum,
was Meditation eigentlich genau ist,
was die Wissenschaft sagt
und um faszinierende Phänomene,
die wir nur in Ansätzen verstehen.
(Rattern)
Leider gibt es keine einheitliche
Definition von "Meditation".
Es existieren Hunderte Techniken,
die unterschiedlicher
nicht sein könnten.
Die meisten von ihnen stammen
aus dem Buddhismus und Hinduismus.
Aber auch der muslimische Drehtanz
der Derwische
ist eine Art von Meditation.
(Monotoner Gesang, bewegte Musik)
Man kann also offensichtlich
meditieren während man sich bewegt.
Yoga, Tai Chi oder die Gehmeditation
würden auch
in diese Kategorie fallen.
(Ruhige Musik)
Natürlich kann Meditation
aber auch so aussehen.
Dann kann man zum Beispiel
seine Atmung fokussieren,
seine Gedanken beobachten,
versuchen, möglichst viel Mitgefühl
und Liebe zu spüren.
Etwas visualisieren
oder sich Fragen stellen.
Ach ja, und ihr kennt bestimmt
alle Mantras wie:
Professor Dr. Sedlmeier unterrichtet
Forschungsmethodik und Evaluation
am Institut für Psychologie
der TU Chemnitz.
Er forscht seit über 20 Jahren
zu Meditation.
In den letzten Jahrzehnten
ist das wissenschaftliche Interesse
an Meditation extrem angestiegen.
Aus gutem Grund.
Meditation erhöht die Intelligenz,
verringert die Angst,
verringert Stress,
erhöht die Leistungsfähigkeit.
Erhöht die Qualität
zwischenmenschlicher Beziehungen.
Schauen wir uns eine typische
Meditation mal genauer an.
Du schließt deine Augen,
fokussierst deine Atmung
und beobachtest alles, was dir an dem
wechselnden Strom der Luft auffällt.
(Ruhige Musik)
Du versuchst, alle anderen Eindrücke
und Ablenkungen kommen
und gehen zu lassen.
Du bringst deine Aufmerksamkeit immer
wieder zurück ins Hier und Jetzt.
Zurück zur Atmung.
Dadurch werden
die beteiligten Netzwerke im Gehirn
trainiert.
Das heißt, es gelingt Ihnen besser,
den Fokus zu halten.
(Ruhige Musik)
Und wenn Sie abdriften,
merken Sie früher,
dass Sie abgedriftet sind
und holen sich zurück.
Das ist Dr. Ulrich Ott.
Er ist Psychologe und Hirnforscher,
erforscht am Bender Institute
of Neuroimaging
an der Universität Gießen
zu Meditation
und veränderten
Bewusstseinszuständen.
(Dynamische Musik)
Das sogenannte
Default Mode Network
umfasst verschiedene Regionen
im Gehirn.
Es wird immer dann aktiv,
wenn wir tagträumen
oder in Gedanken versinken.
Aber auch,
wenn wir über uns selbst,
die Vergangenheit
oder die Zukunft nachdenken.
Durch Meditation lernt man, dieses
Netzwerk quasi herunterzufahren.
Andere Hirnareale,
die uns beim Konzentrieren helfen,
werden währenddessen aktiver.
Wenn du deinen Körper beobachtest,
wird der Teil
in deinem Gehirn trainiert,
der für die Körperwahrnehmung
zuständig ist.
Bei der Gehmeditation
wird der motorische Teil trainiert.
Außerdem kann Meditation
Verbindungen zwischen
verschiedenen Hirnregionen stärken.
Einer der regulierenden Teile
des Gehirns
scheint sich bei Meditierenden
zum Beispiel deutlich besser
mit der emotionalen Zentrale
unseres Gehirns abzustimmen.
Auch die Struktur des Gehirns
scheint sich zu verändern.
Die sogenannte Graue Substanz
ist Teil
unseres Zentralen Nervensystems,
welches quasi alles
in unserem Körper reguliert.
Bei gestressten Menschen verringert
sich die Dichte der Grauen Substanz.
Bei Menschen,
die regelmäßig meditieren,
scheint sie zuzunehmen.
Das wiederum deutet darauf hin,
dass Meditation Stress
zu mindern scheint.
Das alles kann langfristig
eine echten Einfluss
auf deinen Alltag haben.
Vielleicht kannst du dich besser
auf manche Dinge konzentrieren,
bist weniger gestresst,
nimmst deinen Körper
oder deine Umwelt bewusster wahr
oder hast deine Gedanken
und Gefühle besser im Griff.
Dass Meditation wirkt,
das weiß man, es gibt Tausende
von Studien, die das zeigen.
Aber ...
die genauen Mechanismen,
da ist man erst am Anfang,
diese Mechanismen sich anzusehen.
(Klaviermusik)
Je nach Technik,
Person,
Alter und mentaler Verfassung
kann Meditation
sehr unterschiedlich wirken.
Meditation scheint zwar, den meisten
Menschen helfen zu können,
ist aber definitiv
nicht für jeden geeignet.
Welcher Teil von welcher Technik
bei welcher Person
wie wirkt, muss noch
deutlich genauer erforscht werden.
Auch über mögliche Risiken
und Nebenwirkungen
weiß man noch nicht genug.
Die Forschung zu Meditation
hat sich bisher größtenteils
auf westliche Ziele fokussiert.
Es geht darum, sich zu entspannen,
weniger gestresst zu sein
und seine Leistung zu steigern.
Und all das ist auch gut belegt.
Aber was ist
mit den tieferen Erfahrungen,
die Menschen
während der Meditation machen?
Was hat es mit diesen
Bewusstseinszuständen auf sich?
Wozu es eigentlich
ursprünglich entwickelt worden ist,
das sind diese
spirituellen Erfahrungen.
Ja, also tiefe Selbsterkenntnisse,
tiefe Bewusstseinsveränderung.
(Mystische, atmosphärische Musik)
Wo sich das Ich auflöst.
Wo Raum- und Zeitgefühl
komplett verschwinden können.
Oft auch begleitet
von intensiven positiven Emotionen.
Von Glückseligkeit.
Die Forschung zu solchen
Bewusstseinszuständen
weist noch
extrem viele Lücken auf.
Man ist sich aber einig,
dass es sie gibt,
und sie durch Meditation
erreicht werden können.
Eine Art Erleuchtung
ist für viele Meditierende im Westen
nicht das Ziel.
Viel mehr hat sich Meditation
als effektives Mittel
der Selbstoptimierung etabliert.
Außerdem scheint Meditation
ein guter Weg zu sein,
sich selbst und die Welt
um sich herum klarer wahrzunehmen.
Also wenn du keine Vorerkrankungen
oder Ähnliches hast,
probier es doch einfach mal aus.
Wahrscheinlich können wir alle
etwas weniger Stress
und etwas mehr Ruhe und Gelassenheit
gut gebrauchen.
(Ruhige Klaviermusik)
Wir hoffen wie immer,
dass euch dieses Video gefallen hat.
Schreibt uns gerne in die Kommentare,
was ihr von Meditation haltet.
Auf der Endcard findet ihr
unsere Playlist "Wissenschaft".
Außerdem ein Video von "MaiLab"
zu Yoga.
Ansonsten bis zum nächsten Video.